this isn't an Avatar movie it's broken
but ultimately I loved it I absolutely
love all things Pandora and this
beautiful intricate World James Cameron
has built I've even been to Disney World
a couple times to go to the Avatar
themed land where they have the Pandora
and floating mountains and where you can
ride a Banshee so it may come as quite a
shock when I say that Avatar 2 is broken
and in a way it's not really an Avatar
movie for two main reasons the first and
maybe the most obvious reason is that
Avatar the way of water is basically
just an amalgamation of other popular
movies and in particular James Cameron
movies but what exactly do I mean by
that well there are tons of story beats
and plot details that seem like they
were pulled directly out of other films
also spoiler alert if you haven't seen
the way of water for example one of the
main plot details in the film is that
the family is struggling to survive a
sinking ship just like the main plot of
another James Cameron film type Titanic
it's also no coincidence that Kate
Winslet appeared in both movies the
imitation story beats don't stop there
though near the beginning of the film
The Sky people returned to Pandora and
with their rocket thrusters they burned
the forest where the solely family lived
killing thousands of plants and animals
in the process immediately when I saw
this it made me think of the nuclear
apocalypse scene and James Cameron's
Terminator 2 Judgment Day there's also a
third James Cameron movie that comes to
mind obviously the film Alien was a big
inspiration because it stars Sigourney
Weaver and Aliens just like Avatar in
another scene a group of humans is
hunting some large whale-like creatures
for a gold substance called Amrita which
can completely stop human aging this
entire sequence seems to follow the
story of Moby Dick with Captain Ahab
searching for the white whale and its
precious blubber we also see story Beats
from Tarzan and the character of spider
left in the forest by his parents and
raised by a more primitive people
there's also a couple quick references
to Star Wars when large fish is about to
kill loac and an even bigger one comes
to the rescue just like in Star Wars The
Phantom Menace
this is a bigger fish another Star Wars
reference comes at the end of the film
when Colonel korich tells his son spider
to join him stretching out his hand just
like Darth Vader with Luke in The Empire
Strikes Back we also got what seemed to
be a reference to both die hard and John
Wick in the scene where Jake and natiri
rescue their kids aboard the boat after
their son to Tam was killed they were
sneaking around silently killing off
guards just like John McLean and die
hard and getting revenge for their son
just like John Wick getting revenge for
his dog lastly at one point in the movie
loak is literally swallowed by a whale
just like the story of Jonah all of
these references and copied story Beats
make the film seem a bit unoriginal kind
of like the first Avatar film which
basically took Disney's Pocahontas and
copied it beat for beat quick breakdown
a ship carries a man to a strange place
where miners are having issues with the
indigenous people the man explores the
land and meets a local woman who trusts
him after receiving a message from a
magical tree he learns the people's ways
and falls in love with the woman but
he's sentenced to death for bringing in
The Outsiders and is eventually saved by
the woman and helps to defeat The
Outsiders before resolving their
differences I mean come on
if you like what you're seeing hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this now back to the video the next
reason the way of water isn't an Avatar
movie is that it doesn't really Center
on actual avatars since the term Avatar
is in the title you'd expect it to
follow a human driver in an avatar body
but after the events of the first film
almost all of the human drivers are gone
and all of our main characters live
their lives entirely in their own Navi
bodies even the film's antagonists
aren't avatars they're Navi bodies with
human memories transplanted into their
brains so it really isn't an Avatar
movie it's more of a navi movie or
Pocahontas in space 2. all that aside I
really loved this movie and if you
haven't seen it yet or you saw it in 2D
I have to recommend you see it in 3D it
truly was meant to be seen this way if
you think 3D movies are bad or
unnecessary I thought the same thing but
decided Avatar was worth it and boy was
I right 3D technology has advanced so
much over the past 13 years since the
first Avatar film was released and it
really shows in the way of water just to
name a few reasons why this film was so
great the underwater scenes were
absolutely breathtaking no pun intended
Jay CE Cameron decided to not use dry
wet filming like you might see in movies
such as Aquaman since it gives an
unrealistic looking result instead they
used revolutionary underwater motion
capture technology which gave us some of
the best looking water scenes in movie
history it also LED Kate Winslet to beat
the record for the longest amount of
time for holding one's breath in a
filmmaking performance previously held
by Tom Cruise and Mission Impossible
Rogue Nation she smashed the record
holding her breath for over seven
minutes long I also loved the prologue
in the film which helped to catch us up
to what the Solly family had been up to
since we saw them last and gave us a
look into the Solly family's life with
babies being born and adopted and the
parents going out for a date night I
also appreciated the ending to the movie
where Jake opens his eyes in the exact
same way as the end of the first film to
the sound of beating drums I really
appreciated Sigourney Weaver's inclusion
in the film as well especially in the
character of Kiri and her relationship
with Dr Augustine kiri's connection to
Nature and the deity AWA was especially
fascinating to see and I hope it gets
explored more in the future Avatar films
Avatar the seed Bearer Avatar the token
Rider and Avatar the Quest for AWA
lastly I loved how the phrase a sun for
a sun was used in the film initially
natiri used it as a threat to kill
kwara's son's spider after her son
nateam was killed in the end though Jake
used the phrase to explain how their son
natam joined AWA in the afterlife and
how spider joined the soli family the
only other slight issues I had with the
film were how they seemingly just jumped
into speaking English when in the first
movie they spoke navi for the film's
entirety also the story felt very
similar to the original as the family
had to learn a new people's way of life
just like Jake learning the omit Takaya
people's way of life also in some cases
the battle scenes looked like they were
from a video game rather than a movie
Next the film was probably a bit too
long but I love long movies in a quote
from Empire magazine James Cameron said
I don't want anybody whining about
length when they sit in binge watch
television for eight hours I've watched
my kids sit and do five one hour
episodes in a row here's the big social
Paradigm [ __ ] that has to happen it's
okay to get up and go pee lastly the
solely family seems to be in almost the
exact same position as they were at the
beginning of the film since Colonel
korich doesn't ever die first he was
reincarnated in a navi body and then he
was saved from drowning by his not son's
son son you'd expect for the family to
be in a better position by the end of
the movie but they're in just about the
same exact spot as before regardless of
all of this and whether the way of water
is an Avatar movie I absolutely loved it
and highly recommend to anyone who
hasn't seen it
foreign
[Music]